[Music]
it's a law which has enraged the
pro-choice movement
the so-called heartbeat bill is a
near-total ban on abortion it threatened
to sweep away decades of progress on a
woman's right to choose
but now a shifting of the dial a texas
judge has ordered a temporary injunction
on its enforcement calling the bill
flagrantly unconstitutional
among abortion providers there's
cautious celebration we are proud to do
our part to lead the resuming of care in
texas
we
have reopened
our schedule to to expand beyond that
six-week limit in our texas clinics
already
amy had an abortion in texas and now
advocates for those affected by
restrictive laws it is a very safe
procedure it's one of the safest medical
procedures and medication abortion is
safer than tylenol or viagra but the
fact that it's become politicized i
think is you know just devastating it's
devastating to the people that need
abortion care
and it's devastating to their families
and i think it needs to be stopped the
state of texas will appeal the decision
and the legal uncertainty means clinics
are still wary of resuming care this
ruling is a victory for the pro-choice
movement but it's by no means the end of
the story the next battleground in this
national debate over whether abortion
will remain legal is the supreme court
in december it will hear a case from the
state of mississippi where abortion is
currently banned after 15 weeks
it could lead to the overturning of roe
versus wade an historic 1973 ruling
which legalized abortion nationwide
pro-life campaigners like john hope it
will pave the way for more heartbeat
bills across america we want to see
these children in the womb
whose cardiac activity whose heartbeat
starts around six to eight weeks
into the pregnancy we think they should
be protected
from violence
abortion is often used by politicians in
america who harness this strength of
feeling to bring swing voters to the
polls
and what many believe should be a
personal and private decision is now
being dictated by public legal battles
martha kellner sky news washington dc